the risk to children from coronavirus is
a fraction of the risk from flu every
single year no one ever talked about
closing schools for that people say okay
children may not get seriously ill from
this virus but they might pass it on to
their families
really in one study quote we have not
found a single instance of a child
infecting parents they lecture us about
contact tracing well they did it for a
boy with corona virus he came into
contact with 172 classmates and teachers
while symptomatic and didn't transmit
the disease to any of them not one out
of 172 people in Switzerland the
country's head of infectious disease
says scientists quote now know young
children don't transmit the virus
because of all this countless other
countries starting with Denmark had
already begun reopening schools before
the summer break when the president
pointed that out this week the idiot
said our but we have thousands of new
cases a day and Denmark doesn't but
Denmark reopen schools months ago if you
equalize for population size and testing
rates there's nothing like the
difference in case numbers between the
u.s. now and Denmark then and the data
shows that reopening schools didn't
worsen their outbreak at all and yet
here America summer camps are closed and
school plans are in doubt this is not
safe it's harming our children almost a
third of parents say their children's
emotional or mental health is suffering
another third worried that it'll start
hurting their children soon it's hurting
their education and their future
prospects too the evidence is piling up
that remote learning doesn't work
especially for the poorest families and
those in rural areas with unreliable
internet and perhaps worst of all we're
seeing reports of a rise in child abuse
beyond the impact on children
there's the impact on our economy if
kids can't go to school parents can't go
to work he's a farmer from Minnesota
this week the really big question mark
right now is whether they'll be school
here this fall
because the harvest season almost more
than planting is all hands on deck that
would be really really difficult to
manage both kids with no childcare and
by the way schools open one day a week
or three days a week or in the morning
or the afternoon or whatever other
pseudo-scientific bureaucratic claptrap
they come up with it's still a disaster
responding to New York's one two three
day week plan the leading employers
group was crystal clear people will not
be able to go back to work
Australia gets all this it's deputy
chief medical officer said the evidence
does not support avoiding classroom
learning as a means to control Kovan in
Canada they get all this experts at a
Toronto Children's Hospital called for
opening schools with no restrictions
masks they say if worn incorrectly it
could lead to increased risk of
infection and it's not practical for a
child to wear a mask properly for the
duration of a school day strict physical
distancing they say should not be
emphasized to children in the school
setting as it is not practical and could
cause significant psychological harm in
line with all those medical experts
President Trump gets all this we're very
much going to put pressure on governor's
and everybody else to open the schools
to get them open and it's very important
it's very important for our country it's
very important for the well-being of the
student and the parents but with all
this damage all this pain and all this
scientific evidence still there isn't a
clear back to school instruction from
the CDC from the people we're told to
trust
still they Witter on about an abundance
of caution and risk aversion still they
trotted out their weasel words to cover
their you-know-what
here's dr. Falchi this week the broad
approach would be obviously but paying
attention to the safety of the children
which is always paramount but within the
context of doing whatever you can
to safeguard the health and the welfare
of the children we should try to get the
schools open in Denmark their definitive
in Australia in Canada in England in
Switzerland in Iceland for goodness sake
why is our own CDC preposterous Lee
praised by the media as the best public
health agency in the world still hemming
and hawing on these vital questions when
other countries have done the research
and published clear conclusions what
have you been doing dr. Redfield you've
had January February March April May
June no wonder the president is forcing
the pace of course he's right to use the
leverage of federal money but frankly
that is a small proportion and by the
way rightly so
we believe in decentralization on this
show and we believe above all in people
power it's time to use it over this
schools Fiasco if your child's school
won't open this fall demand your money
back so you can find an alternative it's
your child
it's your tax dollars why should you pay
for a service you're not getting that's
our new campaign reopen schools or give
me my school money back take it to the
courts